[Musique]
ensemble quel est l'intérêt d'être
ensemble c'est pour essayer de répondre
à cette question que ce soir j'ai envie
de partager avec vous quelques quelques
idées et quelques expériences qui me
semble montrer la force et la beauté
d'être en groupe et d'être et d'être
ensemble
je dois dire aussi que je suis très
content de pouvoir partager cette soirée
avec vous tous ensemble j'aimerais
d'abord vous parler de mes premiers
amours qui sont les fourmis
elles sont belles non donc j'ai fait
pendant quatre ans à une thèse de
doctorat à l'université de lausanne sur
sur les fourmis
j'aimerais vous expliquer une petite
anecdote c'est comment est-ce que les
gens réagissent quand on réagissait au
moment où j'ai expliqué que j'avais fait
un doctorat pendant quatre ans sur les
formes alors il ya trois types de
réactions possibles
la première réaction c'est un peu comme
ici ce soir c est le rire a beau les
fourmis pendant pendant quatre ans aa
mais comment c'est possible de
travailler sur les fourmis pendant
quatre ans le deuxième type de réaction
c'est à les fourmis c'est vrai je suis
passionné par les fourmis depuis mon
enfance raconte mme en plus sur les sur
les faux et le troisième de type de
réactions qui me semble plus la plus
rigolote
c'est à les fourmis c'est vrai j'en ai
plein dans ma cuisine comment est ce que
je peux les exterminer bien sûr pendant
ma pendant ma thèse de doctorat j'ai pas
étudier comment exterminer les fourmis
moi ce que j'ai étudié en fait c'est les
fourmis des bois comme on voit comment
on peut le voir sur cette sur cette
photo les fourmis des bois en fait c'est
ces fourmis qui forme de grand dôme
d'aiguilhe de conifères dans les forêts
de moyenne altitude en suisse entre
autres donc ces fourmis récolte des
morceaux des morceaux de résine d'épicéa
c'est dommage on voit sur la photo on
voyait juste en bas là mais ça a disparu
à l'affichage
donc en gros ces fourmis récolte des
morceaux de résine d'épicéa quelle
qu'elles intègrent dans leurs colonies
et cette résine est produite à la base
pas reliés par des parts des épices ya
des conifères
pour lutter contre des camps des
pathogènes donc la résine a des
propriétés antibactériennes et
antifongiques est donc dans ma thèse de
doctorat
on a réussi à démontrer que cette cette
collecte résine était un comportement de
médication c'est à dire que grâce à la
résine les fourmis peuvent mieux lutter
contre les infections bactériennes et
fongiques est donc être être être en
meilleure santé
d'une certaine manière c'est assez
original dans le sens où on connaît des
des comportements de médication chez des
oiseaux chez des primates
mais si les insectes a été rarement ça a
été rarement documenté donc ce que
j'aimerais vous dire avec ça c'est que
chez les fourmis une première chose
c'est que l'union fait la force donc
être ensemble on est plus fort en fait
d'une part mais d'autre part aussi le
fait de vivre en groupe permet à de
nouveaux comportements comme la
médication de surgir en conclusion c'est
le disons les caractéristiques du groupe
sont plus que la somme des
caractéristiques de chacun des individus
voilà pour les fourmis heureusement
pendant mes dix ans à l'université j'ai
pas seulement j'ai pas seulement étudié
les fourmis j'ai aussi eu la chance de
découvrir
ceci alors ceci caisse c'est le monde on
borie le mont boris est une montagne et
tabulaire situé dans le nord dans le
nord du mali est donc durant ma thèse
j'ai été approché par des amis botaniste
qui qui se sont intéressés à cette à
cette montagne pour une raison bien
particulière c'est que le sommet de la
montagne est difficilement accessible
aux êtres humains et donc il ya une
biodiversité particulière sur le sur le
sommet de la montagne comparer avec les
alentours où là il ya la pression
humaine liés à la récolte du bois de
chauffe par exemple ou liées à haouch
havre qui viennent qui viennent qui
viennent peut être donc mes amis
botanistes ont voulu étudier cette
biodiversité dans l'objectif d'abord de
pouvoir de pouvoir la protéger mais
aussi également de créer une offre de
d'éco tourisme dans la région qui puisse
permettre de bénéficier aux populations
aux populations locales
alors c'est bien sympa de vouloir
étudier la biodiversité sur une montagne
tabulaire au mali mais encore faut-il se
rendre sur le plateau
donc c'est tout tu ne sais tout une
c'est toute une excursion qui s'est
construit un groupe ensemble avec ce
groupe de jeunes étudiants en suisse et
également avec des collègues des
collègues maliens donc il s'agit d'abord
bomba de prendre l'avion jusqu'à bamako
la capitale du mali
ensuite de faire un trajet de bus d'une
journée entre bamako et le village le
village d'ambo rit donc des bus aux
conditions africaines
arrivé dans le village dans le village
de hombori préparer l'excursion donc
l'idée c'était de rester une semaine au
sommet pour faire des pour faire des
prélèvements d'insectes de plantes et
s'est donc préparé on avait l'intention
de rester une semaine donc il s'agissait
aussi de deux dents de la nourriture
d'emmener de l'eau de préparer le
matériel pour les prélèvements etc etc
ensuite environ quatre heures de marche
d'approché pour arriver jusqu au pied de
la falaise dans des conditions assez
difficiles surtout surtout de chaleur
disons dans cette région là qui est la
région sahélienne il fait vraiment très
chaud et ensuite faire la montée de la
falaise on avait installé une sorte de
via ferrata pour arriver jusqu'au
jusqu'au sommet donc c'était des
conditions qui je dois dire était très
très éprouvante et sa grâce au groupe
qu'on a qu'on a réussi à le faire à le
faire ensemble
mais en gros voilà ce que ça donne quand
on arrive quand on arrive au sommet
comme vous pouvez le voir j'avais adopté
les les
les vêtements local pour le projet pour
protéger du soleil
heureusement arrivée au sommet voilà ce
qu'on découvre c'est une vue donc du
sommaire juste après juste après la
pluie avec on voit quelques goodies
comme ça et on voit différentes
différentes autres montagnes ta bulle
hier tabulaire au loin donc pour moi
c'était une aventure de jeunesse et dans
le sens où c'était en groupe qu'on a
réussi à qu'on a réussi à faire cette
excursion et moi ça m'a montré un peu
qu'ensemble on arrive à aller plus loin
on arrive à aller plus haut d'une
certaine manière
donc voilà ensuite j'ai terminé mon
doctorat mon papier en poche
qu'est-ce que j'ai décidé de faire j'ai
décidé de changer complètement de
direction professionnelle
en fait j'avais envie de bouger j'avais
envie de trouver un emploi ou où j'avais
un impact plus fort sur le sur la vie
des gens et donc je me suis
dirigés vers le secteur de l'humanitaire
j'ai postulé avec le cicr j'ai postulé
pour le cicr donc j'ai passé six ans sur
le terrain avec avec le cicr
j'imagine que vous connaissez le cicr lé
c'est une organisation humanitaire qui a
comme objectif de protéger et assister
les victimes de conflits armés
donc j'aimerais d'abord vous parlez de
vous parler de mon expérience aux
colombes donc dans certaines situations
le cicr facilite la libération de
personnes retenues par des groupes armés
en fait en tant qu'intermédiaire
intermédiaire neutre et donc moi j'étais
dans un bureau à médine donc en colombie
et on avait été approché par la famille
d'un jeune ingénieur qui avaient été
enlevés par un groupe armé dans une
région minière du nord delà du nord de
la colombie
on avait assez ans étaient dix ans on
était assez proche avec cette cette
famille on avait essayé un moment donné
de faire une de ces de faire une
opération de libération à dos de mule
dans une région très montagneuse de
colombie donc on était partis pendant
une semaine vraiment dans des conditions
assez assez difficile en fait on était
arrivé dans une finca a perdu dans la
dans les montagnes colombiennes où le
contact qu'on devait rencontrer n'était
pas là en fait est donc la seule à la
première mission s'était soldée par un
échec
ce qui est toujours très difficile en
fait de l'annoncer à la famille qui eux
pensaient retrouver leur leurs êtres
chers disons après dix-huit mois de
séparation
donc ça c'était assez difficile de le
partager avec eux il s'avère que
quelques mois plus tard le groupe nous
contacter pour
procéder à la libération cette fois ci
les informations étaient vraiment
crédible et la libération n'allait pas
se faire a mis bas d'autres mule comme
comme la première comme le premier essai
mais en hélicoptère et donc arrive le
jour j de la libération ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que pour organiser une
libération c'est tout une opération
logistique mais aussi pas mal de
pression autour de ce genre d'opération
il ya bien sûr la famille mais il ya
aussi la présidence d'un colombie il ya
la police il ya les médias qui sont là
et c'est donc qu'il ya toute une
pression qui se construit petit à petit
le matin le matin de l'opération la
première chose à faire c'est de coller
des autocollants dudu de la croix rouge
sur l'hélicoptère l'idée c'est comment
va survoler des zones qui sont qui sont
potentiellement comptes reliés par des
par des groupes armés l'idée c'est qu'on
reconnaisse hélicoptère qu'on ne prenne
pas pour un hélicoptère de la police ou
de l'armée
et bien sûr pour éviter de se faire de
se faire canarder donc on colle les
autocollants et ensuite on attend la
formation de la part du groupe ils
doivent nous transmettre des les
coordonnées gps par radio pour savoir où
est-ce qu'on doit se rendre vers 9
heures comme ça on reçoit les ans reçoit
les coordonnées finalement on arrive à
faire le contact on reçoit les
coordonnées on s'envole avec
l'hélicoptère tout le monde ment dans
les commentaires je transmets les
coordonnées aux pilotes et on s'envole
on arrive dans 1 après 20 minutes de vol
environ
on arrive dans la zone de rendez vous ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que pour un
hélicoptère atterrir dans la jungle il
faut une zone de 30 mètres de diamètre
et qui soit relativement plate pour que
les hélicoptères puissent se poser sans
problème
donc le groupe le groupe armé doit
signalisés cette zone là avec une
colonne de fumée ou avec ou avec des
draps blancs en fait pour qu'on puisse
le voir depuis depuis le ciel donc on
regard on arrive à identifier une zone
l'on s'approche on voit le filet de
fumée
on essaie de se poser hélas la zone n'a
pas été très bien choisis et donc
l'hélicoptère arrive pas à se poser en
premier et c'est un deuxième essai au
final le pilote me dit bon ben j'ai dit
m je vais laisser l'hélicoptère
quasiment posé sur le sol
laissez les pales tournée et toi tu vas
descendre et toi tu vas descendre pour
rencontrer la personne qui nous attend
donc je descends je m'approche et une
personne qui m'attend avec le visage le
visage masqué
et qui me dit c'est pas ici l'endroit du
rendez vous j'ai de nouvelles
coordonnées il faut que je monte dans
l'hélicoptère avec vous pour aller au
nouvel endroit
moi je vérifie qu'il n'est pas armés
parce qu'ils auraient pas le droit en
étant armée de monter dans un
hélicoptère du de la croix rouge et donc
c'est pas le cas et donc on monte à
l'hélicoptère je transmets les
coordonnées au pilote --un mais ça c'est
pas normal ça je sais pas pourquoi ça
avance tout seul donc je transmets les
coordonnées ou aux pilotes et on va on
se dirige vers la nouvelle vers le
nouvel endroit là c'est beaucoup plus
facile le trajet très court on trouve
facilement l'endroit on atterrit je
descende l'hélicoptère et je vois une
personne devant moi hirsute avec une
longue
un jeune homme hirsute avec une longue
barbe qui m'attend et qui me sourit et
sel et on dresse le jeune ingénieur qui
a passé 18 mois 18 mois dans la jungle
donc c'est une première rencontre
magique on s'assied ensuite avec avec le
groupe armé il est entouré d'une dizaine
de jeunes hommes le visage masqué avec
leur avec leur avec leur kalachnikov et
juste le commandant qui lui est un
visage est un visage découvert donc on
fait quelques salutations d'usagé cetera
un contrôle de santé du de léon
tendresse pour s'assurer qu'ils peuvent
bien voyager qui peut bien voyager avec
nous et c'est le départ on monte dans
l'hélicoptère
on s'envole et là la pression tombe
premier premiers instants de bonheur
c'est la fin du calvaire 18 mois de
calvaire pour pour pour les andrés c'est
vivre la liberté et la déjà waouh c'est
un moment d'une intensité incroyable
on se dirige vers l'aérodrome où
attendent les parents l'hélicoptère a
atterri leone andres descend sur le
tarmac
il aperçoit ses parents un peu plus loin
il commence il marche puis cours en
direction de ses parents et et il tombe
dans les bras dans les bras l'un de
l'autre et la wka deuxième instants
d'une intensité vraiment vraiment
incroyable alors là tout le monde pleure
moi je pleure
les pilotes de les pilotes d'hélicoptère
pleurs les policiers pleurs là c'est
vraiment un moment d'une d'une intensité
d'une intensité rare j'aimerais partager
avec vous ces photos
qui sont qui sont pas très bonnes
qualités parce qu'elles ont été prises
par téléphone mais qui pour moi montre
vraiment la beauté de cette de cet
instant on voit les noms adresses de
face et ses deux parents de dos et pour
moi la première image c'est vraiment la
douleur de la séparation et des
retrouvailles la deuxième image c'est le
soulagement d'être de nouveau enfin
ensemble et finalement le bonheur le
bonheur d'être avec sa famille donc moi
je me suis senti vraiment disons
privilégié de pouvoir participer de
pouvoir de pouvoir de pouvoir faire
quelque chose pour cette course est pour
cet incroyable événement
maintenant j'aimerais rapidement vous
dire deux mots sur le travail du cicr en
prison donc le cicr visite des détenus
dans les prisons pour monitorer leurs
conditions de détention et leur
condition de leurs conditions de
traitement en fait moi j'ai travaillé
beaucoup là-dedans en afghanistan ce que
le cicr une condition sine qua none pour
le cicr pour faire des visites c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon des es tu
et des entretiens sans témoin c'est à
dire que le cicr doit pouvoir
s'entretenir sans la présence des
autorités et des gardes avec les détenus
pour que ceux ci puissent parler sans
crainte des problèmes qui peuvent qui
peuvent avoir et quelque chose qui m'a
vraiment marqué c'est que souvent dans
la dans lé travail en détention c'est un
travail qui a qui est difficile où il ya
disons beaucoup d'efforts pour pas
forcément beaucoup d'impact il ya
beaucoup de besoins mais le solitaire
peut pas toujours faire grand chose et
mais par contre pour les pour les
détenus qu'on rencontre le fait
simplement de s'asseoir avec eux de
partager de les écouter c'est déjà une
énorme valeur ajoutée même si
matériellement on peut pas faire grand
chose pour eux cette ce moment de
partage et déjà quelque chose qui est
vraiment qui est vraiment fort pour moi
je vais pas vous dire non plus que c'est
tout le temps pis elle l'avait que l'on
reçoit que des fleurs moi je me rappelle
bien un détenu en afghanistan un ancien
commandant d'un groupe jihadiste
international que je visitais de manière
régulière et donc lui pendant une
demi-heure ses terres il critiquait le
cicr votre travail ça sert à rien
l'assistance que vous distribuez
distribuer c'est de la mauvaise qualité
toi même ton travail tu sais pas le
faire etc etc etc et donc pendant une
demi-heure il critiquait énormément mais
au bout d'une demi heure ils repartaient
détendu le sourire aux lèvres et donc ça
en fait c'est ce que moi je pouvais lui
a portés pendant pendant sept pendant
cette cet entretien 700 témoins donc
voilà en conclusion lorsque ce que tous
ces expériences m'ont amené à penser
c'est que l'être humain est un être
sociable par nature je pense vraiment
que c'est grâce au groupe que l'être
humain peut se peut s'élever en fait
et quand je dis s'est levé je pense pas
forcément assez élevé en hélicoptère ou
à s'élever sur une montagne au mali mais
je pense plutôt à réaliser vraiment son
potentiel est en tout cas moi dans mon
expérience je sais que c'est souvent
grâce à la force du groupe que j'ai
réussi à prendre les décisions parfois
des décisions difficiles que j'ai dû
prendre ou de trouver aussi la
motivation d'essayer de me changer
devenir quelqu'un quelqu'un de meilleur
et c'est vrai que dans le monde actuel
où il ya beaucoup de peur où il ya
beaucoup de gens ou enfin on est souvent
un peu en perte en perte de repères où
on allait
le populisme qui qui qui monte en flèche
on a plutôt tendance à repousser les
réfugiés où les migrants dans la mer
plutôt que de les accueillir à bras
ouverts je pense que c'est de notre
responsabilité à tous de chercher le
contact de créer du lien et de partager
et c'est vraiment en même temps c'est un
bonheur de faire confiance au groupe de
recevoir la confiance du groupe
donc en même temps on se fait du bien à
soi même et donc à mon avis c'est une
des manières de construire un monde
meilleur où chacun puisse puisse trouver
sa place et donc ma conclusion c'est
faites vous plaisir et partager merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]